I don't think through my crushes like that, I'm not like,
I'm like, okay. I like him. Yeah.
But that's the thing you can like them as a friend, not Oh.
Using bad words is okay. Three, two,
one go.
You shouldn't swear. That's a common fact. But then again,
you have to let your anger out some way.
So that's why I only somewhat disagree using well
words. Can they have meaning? And when you use them, it means something.
So when you use a bad word, it means like you're angry and you're not happy,
but when you need to use them, you can just scream in your pillow,
not yelling at someone.
And I don't think that you should just scream into your pillow.
That's just going to bottle up your emotions.
And that's just going to get worse and worse.
It's just going to eventually burst and you're going to see even more bad words
than you should. Yeah. What if you just get a stress ball,
but that's for a specific, like physical,
or you said that if somebody is like really angry,
so what if you just get a stress ball? But it depends on the person,
in my opinion, squishing something. Isn't going to make me any happier. Like,
let's say like you have like a best friend. No. And then like you, I don't know,
like you say like a swear word to them, then maybe they'll just like,
not wanna hang out with you because you like cuss and all.
I'm sorry if people here are not Christian, but it's against the Bible.
You shouldn't swear because it can also hurt a lot of people's feelings if you
swear directly at them. But yeah, you shouldn't do it.
I'm Christian. So I guess I'll just put in disagree.
I have a crush on someone three, two,
one go.
Uh, okay. Ooh.
We're going to find out some romantic loving today's.
You should not love someone when you're this like,
like this age, it's like more of a mature thing. Like you,
you should just like, like people as friends, you shouldn't like,
love people. Like you want to marry them and stuff. Like,
like that's like high school, college thing at this age,
we just like have crushed. We don't like,
love them to where we're marrying them and we're going to have kids.
And I don't think through my crushes like that, I'm not like,
like, I'm like, I'm like, okay. I like him. Yeah. Yeah.
But that's the thing you can like them as a friend, not, Oh,
it's not like your choice. You can't like make yourself like forced,
like not like 'em or have a crush on them. It's a way of the heart though. Yeah.
It's okay. Liking someone is just like, shouldn't be too excited about this,
that you're going to like, so don't keep.
Kids should be allowed to have cell phones. Three,
two, one go.
Yeah.
I strongly agree because what if let's disagree to disagree?
Oh, sorry. It's okay, bro.
What if you got lost and your parents said that you
couldn't have a cell phone? I wouldn't be able to call anybody.
Cause I wouldn't have a cell phone.
I have a phone and I use it for certain reasons.
Like to FaceTime my friends and like face on my family and texts. And then like,
I kind of don't really think we should have one is because we usually want to
hang out with our friends, not stay on really devices all day,
children just, they could break the cell phones and drop it.
It's it depends on what age.
So that's why I believe it should be teenagers can have cell phones because they
actually understand the world how to not break for like some like, um,
kids do have responsibility to from their parents,
but also because children could just access a bunch of really inappropriate
things and you can go into like a like dark web or something on accident.
And then like you could accidentally give your address.
Like while playing like a game you could like accidentally like be like leaking
in social media is in all parents technology.
These days you can put child lock on your phone. Uh, that's a thing on YouTube.
You can put child walk. I'm pretty sure they can't like access certain things.
If you post something wrong on accident, it stays there forever.
Even though you delete it, it's still up there.
People can see that and then they can get into stuff that you don't want them to
see.
I understand what racism is.
Three, two, one go.
This is the saying, I feel like I've heard many people say, um,
it doesn't matter. What's on the outside.
That counts it's what's on the inside that counts.
Like what does like the skin like have to like affect you by back in the
forties and fifties, black people in Hispanic,
people were being like harassed by white
people. No offense. And it's fine.
Like they used to get water hose.
I know that black people didn't like that because what if the white people were
black people and they were being treated like that.
Like they don't know what it feels like.
They just think that they have all the power.
They can just do whatever they want it because we were helpless.
People are stereotyped over the color of the skin,
which doesn't make any sense because everyone's mean at some point everyone's
upset at some point. Everyone's nice at some point,
but I just don't get why people are stereotyped by their skin.
We're all the same. We're all human beings. If we're,
if we're from different places, it's like, if it's alert, there's a lot of sun.
You have more melanin in your skin. If it's like more cold, barely any sun,
you have less Mellon.
We have to respect each other with the same ways you want to be respected
and people get killed just by protesting.
And then it just makes me so sad.
Like they're just trying to get their own right. It's a good way to put.
I'm afraid of climate change. Three, two,
one go.
I'm born to be here.
Okay. So there's no point of being afraid of climate change.
Like you can be like, concerned about it,
like about the animals that live in like different climates,
like places, but places. Yeah.
There's no point of you to be afraid because you're used to like warm weather
and like a little cooler weather, but you can be concerned about it.
It's actually our fault.
We're making more pollution and pollution and pollution. It's making the air.
It's why you're just not concerned about it.
That's why people are switching to electric cars because gasoline is part of it.
But, but people are now like changing to electricity,
but still electricity is made with gas.
And I don't know what it's called, but there's like over the planet,
there's like a big protection from the sun rays.
It was really extreme on us and burn ourselves to death.
But we're destroying that. And that's why we're endangering ourselves too.
I just really remember. But like grammar, like when we had to like go back away,
like from like some of our homes,
like how it was like showing like a couple of weeks ago because like fires,
I was going on wildfire, climate change. Maybe we should be scared.
I'm not saying that you should have to. Well, that's just being concerned.
There's no, there's no point of being afraid. Like, Oh my gosh,
you're going to die. There's like no point because you are going to die.
That's the thing. Not for sure. But you might
[inaudible] but you will guarantee you have third degree burns be drowned to the
point where you become a fish.
I miss going to school in person three,
two, one go,
Oh gosh. I'm. So.
I strongly agree on going to school because you can like
get more help from your teachers and you get to see your friends again,
in my opinion,
there's just no reason to have to want to do school at,
in pretty soon.
And that's just way less safety with this whole COVID-19 going on.
But then as for distractions, you can just turn on safety lock or something.
We're get grounded.
There's not only distractions on your phone and your computer like that.
You can just put a lock on. You can also get distracted.
Like if you're in your room,
because I'm sure your parents will be doing something in the other rooms.
But I also like,
feel like school is great because your teacher can give you like one-on-one time
and go to your desk and help you with a certain problem.
And you also get to like, see your friends. A bunch of my friends, I know have,
um, do online and are like failing their classes.
And the exact same thing happened to me except like I was winging it like
online. And then I had like straight like F's, but then like,
I like went to like the school school and then changed all my grades to A's and
B's.
Adult are always right. Three, two,
one go.
Don't completely disagree. I'm sure that every adult isn't always right,
because women are always right.
But you can have some credits, telekinetic, mind,
power that lets you be right. A hundred percent of the time.
Sometimes my teacher gets things wrong and sometimes the students have to
correct. My teacher,
my grandma has a daycare and one of her helpers that used to work for
her, she didn't go to school.
So she kind of didn't know anything. No one's ever like right.
All the time. Like, no matter if you're an adult or a kid,
I feel like parents just say they're always right.
Because they like want you to do something else.
Instead of playing video games all day, they want you to go outside. So like,
I feel like that's outside. I run out your energy.
Making friends is hard. Three,
two go.
Really talkative. So I will just like go up to someone and I'll be like, Hey,
what's your name? And then we'll start a full-blown conversation.
And then we'll swap numbers.
And also acting makes it a lot easier to make friends like this.
Like when you're working on set with someone you're literally just like with so
many other kids that you can make friends with.
So I feel like it's easy whenever I'm doing like my magic to like,
like someone I did make like quite a lot of friends and all, um, it was easier.
I was talking and it wasn't like talking about like art stuff.
But I was talking about like what I've loved. And while I was doing Juan,
I'm going to have to disagree with you because you said that you did
a magic trick and now people want to be your friend. Right?
What if you are a regular kid,
some people just want to be friends with you because you're either famous or
you're rich. I know, but I wasn't rich or famous. You're really cool. So like,
what if you were just like a basic kid,
do you think they would still be friends with you? Well,
most likely because some of it was like out on,
like outside was what's on the inside of that counted right there at that time,
I just be myself and I just see if they wanted to be friends with me or not,
because it all, it just depends on what they think of me.
Sometimes I have to act to get friends because
sometimes I, I hear their conversations and they're saying that they like,
don't like to be friends with my type of personality.
I kind of feel like I'm lying because it's like,
it's not like truly me and I just,
I prefer getting friends like the way I actually am.
I don't.
Want to grow up three, two, one, go.
I honestly want to grow up because it's like part of life and you just get
to experience different things. Um, depending on your age,
I want to be like a kid,
but like staying in care forever is like being in school for a long time
and like re like redoing your grades. And it's like not fun. And you, if you,
when you grow up, you can have a job and do what you love. I mean,
technically as long as you're good at school,
if you just keep repeating the same classes,
it's not the worst thing that can happen is just like, you're,
it's like you're reviewing this same thing you learned last year.
And like it you're, and then you get bored of it.
That's why you want to move onto something new.
I strongly agree on not growing up because I won't have to pay any
bills. Once you grow up,
you learn a lot more so you can get a job and then it's easier to pay bills
and pay taxes.
I want grew up because at the same time you get older and older life does go
on and you really won't have a childhood again.
And change is good and change can be bad, but you'll know too.
Awesome.
[inaudible].